okay i'm hearing all about these great
visual novels and they sound crazy
but i don't know if i'm just a person
who's never going to get into visual
novels because of how i am like i
is is danganronpa a visual novel because
i felt like
i felt like it was yeah okay because
that's that [ __ ] dragged on danganronpa
is
is kind of half visual novel half
mystery game because it's visual novel
in the aspect of
when you're going through the story
elements
it's 100 visual novel yeah like in the
way it looks and the way it presents the
story but
when it comes to the actual murder
mysteries you have to solve there's a
bit of
exploration that happens and the whole
part of when you go to the actual trial
that's a whole game in and of itself
yeah that's true i mean
i just god i remember being so
frustrated playing that i don't know why
which one did you play though the first
one okay i don't play with this
is it bad the second one is by father i
thought everyone said like the third
one's the worst the third one is the
worst but
first one's not great either first one i
i didn't i wasn't a huge fan of the i
played all three
first one was okay yeah the second one
though
is by far the most optimized the best in
terms of like game plans of the story in
terms of characters
everything yeah and then the third one
they just they dropped the ball dude i'm
so disappointed
they bombed that so [ __ ] hard it was
the ending to the third one which i was
just like
you made me sit through three whole
games of this [ __ ] and that's how you
end it
[ __ ] you if the if you had to like pitch
it to me to get me into visual novels
i'm sure there are some viewers at home
how would you do that because like as
somebody who's never experienced visual
novel and doesn't really think that
he'll like it i mean do you like books
um it's been a while well there's your
stuff
there's our first problem the problem is
with books is that i never seek them out
but every time i've read a book i've had
a great time
yeah okay then that might just be the
case with visual novels or maybe all you
need
is just that one visual novel that you
can relate to yeah
and because you know that the pool of
visual novels is so
deep what's like some beginner
recommendations for visual novels that
like everyone must
honestly doki doki really yeah doki doki
is a great like
it's it's it's just a great starter one
because it's so short and
if you can get through like the the
worst part of doki doki unfortunately is
like the first half where it's just how
it normally is
it's just setting up the scene and
everything um but
like at the halfway point hits and it's
like oh oh this is this has got a lot of
interesting
in defense of doki doki though the
reason why the first half is so boring
is because it's parodying visual novels
yeah yeah
so knowing that if you go into doki doki
with that mindset then the first half is
a little more bearable
but the thing is if you're not
interested in the actual the problem
with visual novels is if you're not
invested in the story
you're not going to enjoy it no matter
how flashy or good it is
yeah right and that's the unfortunate
thing is that so many visual novels get
passed under the rock because
too many people are just too lazy to get
into the story yeah yeah exactly
yeah this guy i hate story in videos
okay then here's here here's a question
to you then uh what are like
some visual novel adaptations for anime
that you've just really enjoyed that's a
good question
have you watched a lot ah i think i have
maybe you have watched a lot and you
just didn't know
you know because i can't remember the
top of my head which one okay so some of
them might be steins gates
i like stein's skate a lot but that felt
like a visual novel when i was just
watching that
yeah i mean there's lots of moments
where they weren't afraid to like
be boring yeah like okay not be boring
but they weren't afraid to let you sit
with mundane situations it's a very slow
character development amazing anime
though yeah like i [ __ ] loved that
and it's an amazing visual yeah yeah
because i remember i had had the game on
360.
i just never played it right right i
don't know why i never played it i think
i bought i watched the anime i thought
whoa i want to play this i bought it
never played it because i was like